I have another Blade Runner watch for
you this week a lot of the designs for
everything in the Blade Runner universe
we're done by a guy named Sid Mead Mead
was a futurist and an artist he did work
for a Ford Motor Company his designs
today tend to look a little 1960s ish
there's a lot of chrome there's a lot of
white spaceships but for Blade Runner he
did that kind of retro fitted look the
feeling that there were old buildings
with new stuff computers on the outside
he did some vehicles in he did parking
meters you barely see him just for a
second the movie but some of his
paintings that they released later you
can really see the designs close-up me
really spent a lot of time making these
things look like parking meters but also
looked like something from the future
they had lights and sensors and some
kind of indicator on them they were very
different than the parking meters that
we had then in 1982 which you put a coin
into and turn the dial they were like
you know vending machines well a couple
years ago San Francisco started
installing these
they take credit cards and debit cards
and city issued cards you can use your
cell phone to call and pay via your cell
phone accounts there are sensors
embedded in the road that can tell when
a car is parked there the city can
adjust the pricing on them and the
timing
they are super futuristic now you might
know that in cities parking is a big
deal and some of the latest theories
about how cities work say that parking
should actually be less not more that it
keeps people driving around makes
downtown's more active in Los Angeles
they're actually starting a system
whereby you can get on your phone a
listing of where the parking spaces are
so you learn to drive around as much
well things never used to look that way
in the real world but now I would say
maybe just a little but thanks to Sydney
and Blade Runner we're almost there
you